can I just ask you what do you like
about news number I like the quality of
life down here the pace of life very
good community feel within newton abbot
and the villages and things quite quirky
this what for you is the best thing
about newton abbot pay it personally I
think it's the facilities in the area
we'd be working in the town center it's
the shop in being able to go out for
lunch time areas where you can actually
go and sit down another lunch for parks
and everything so it's a really nice
place to work and also to move I think
the Greens places I have a dog access to
green space is much better than totnes
also the town it's very earthy I quite
like that enough attention I'm from the
north and it's nice going down south and
find a place like this it's an earthy
and I working-class town is what it is
well when I'm not working here I like
going out on the on the high street
there's a very shops down there and also
I quite like going to the races are nice
now but it's quite nice family day well
I've been working a 23 years the paper
really cross-section of people enjoyable
place minutes and see someone going on
as always
do you think it's easy for local retired
people to find or to afford a home in
the area to afford a home if you're
retired unless you're selling one would
be very difficult unless you've got a
good income coming like the people
coming from London and places like this
have sold a good home there are places
down here are expensive to just buy into
especially if you're going into one of
these warden controlled places there
they are expensive not perhaps to buy
but the maintenance fees are hiring can
you just tell us a little bit about how
you've got to be living in Buckland now
I qualified for the home to own scheme
which is the shared ownership scheme and
when one of these houses became
available i was able to qualify for one
of these so luckily it means that me and
my family have got a nice safe place to
live in Buckland which i think is a
lovely area of Newton Abbot could you
just tell us a little bit about the
shared ownership and shared ownership is
a scheme run through team housing but I
think most housing associations do it
it's where you are able to buy the
portion of the house yourself and then
rent the other piece of the house but
from the other own I e-team housing it
means that you can get an affordable
mortgage for an amount and then also an
affordable rent for the bit that you
don't own but you have an opportunity
then it later date to buy more of the
house so you become you can be no more
eventually and and what are the main
challenges that you experience when
trying to find a place to live and
basically affordability and I'm a local
person and
I think that Nash nationally our wages
are quite low and the housing prices are
high so it does cut cut you out from
owning and i would say an average house
is about 150,000 people don't earn
enough to be able to afford that kind of
house
Ashley thank you very much for talking
to us today in newton abbot what type of
property is most sought after by your
customers the strongest demand is for
average family homes there's plenty of
buyers for that type of property demand
is also quite strong at a luxury end of
the market of course this viewer
potential buyers who can afford that
type of property and where do most of
the people looking for houses in our
area come from a large percentage that
we are moving within the area but there
are also a good number of buyers from
the wealthier part so you can typically
wear properties higher price than it is
in use another
a couple of weeks ago if I was asked
that oughta probably said I normally do
have a problems employing staff or the
right people applying we normally use in
you know the local newspapers and a job
center and also advertising in the
window and we seem to struggle
especially for key positions or train
skill positions like restaurant managers
pub managers chefs and we seem to have a
lot of not so skilled staff applying for
a job but the kind of key positions I
think we do struggle with sometimes here
I ask you how long it's been since she
left school it's been a year and what
are you doing at the moment the selects
partner okay could you tell me a little
bit about what that course is and it's
basically my English Maths ICT for key
skills and social skills just improves
that I can do my gone to my lover to
language assesses and that's an able to
get brilliant gcse's and it helps of
going into work and things like that and
what sort of job are you looking for
once when account
and do you think that you could get the
training and qualifications you need to
be an accountant in newton abbot yeah I
do I think and like that's quite a few
places in it when Albert got independent
places that do accountancy staff sir and
once you've got those qualifications do
you think that you will be able to get a
job doing accountancy in this area yeah
and if you could change one thing about
the town what would it be big papa the
roads had some road around it so we can
get into the town without under q & B
pen in is an absolute nightmare just
accident there this morning which closed
it you know and if you've got to come
from the other side of pen in or the
other side from 3038 way I mean getting
into newton abbot early in the morning
or late in the afternoon is typically
scenarios responders and really they
suffer because we haven't got a decent
bypass the second one of course if
everyone that lives the other side of
painting roundabout is please put the
bypass in so i don't have to sit in a
traffic for 40 minutes every morning to
go into newton abbot of travel half a
mile
and you think the recent enhancements to
newton abbot have made a difference or
they've made a huge difference I think
investment in tans is really important
and newton abbot has been so lucky that
we've had this investment in Courtney
Street the investment around the clock
tower on the library in the new street
furniture and one would obviously hope
to to see further investment going
forward but it's been a huge benefit for
the town and we get lots of lots of
visitors to the town who's saying how
attractive it is and what changes would
you make to improve the shopping offer
or to attract more people well I don't
think we can do much more to improve the
shopping offer I think we've actually
got a very good shopping offer it is
very diverse and the other thing you've
got to remember is even if another
national retailer wanted to come into
town I haven't got a space big enough to
put it at the moment so that's that's
one of the things you've got to look at
but one of the things that I would like
to do more is to really emphasize the
market side of things and I think this
whole local food element you know with a
food festival or something like that I
think we can do a lot more with that to
promote the tan for uncommon we've had
from people that we've spoken to you
today is about the high number of and
charity shops as they perceive it would
you like to comment on that I get this
comment a lot as you can imagine and
people do say there are a lot of charity
shops but in reality the number of
charity shops that we have here in
newton abbot is is actually no more than
the percentage in any other town and one
thing you have got to look at is they
actually do quite a lot of good for the
town they bring a lot of football they
are they are very popular businesses and
when people come to town to you know do
the charity shops they also shop in the
other shops in the town so but it's
certainly no bigger a percentage than
any other town it's it's a part of the
retaining life charity shops
one thing that you could change right
knee tablet what would that be and I
would say to bring you more facilities
for children in the area especially like
during six weeks holidays and things
like that so that local communities can
come into the time center be more
younger people in pensions coming to
retire so that would be so more young
people living in the area do you mean
yeah it's creating more jobs as well put
jobs into the local community because
myself I've had to actually go elsewhere
to find a job so I'm having to commute
now and to be able to find work and is
that something